[Music]
fresh off her two Golden Globe
nominations mary j blige ages legacy was
literally cemented in Hollywood as the
singer received her star on the Walk of
Fame and on her birthday no less I was
there for the exciting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel awesome I'm so happy I'm so
blessed 2018 is come in with a bang or
or hollow scream it's loud I want to
thank God for this moment because it
doesn't have to be like this Mary I want
you to enjoy this you came from Yonkers
Westchester New York you had a dream
back down looking this is you 1992 right
around the same time or your debut album
do you believe that yeah that's right
this is my baby right here what advice
do you have for that young in right
there you're beautiful
love yourself people love you there's
been times that I in my career that I
didn't even want to step out my house
because I was hurt so bad but God gave
me the strength I'm so grateful that on
this born day today is my birthday
January 11 God has put my name on a star
a star
[Music]
you